depuis 2015 nous avons besoin de moyens
dans cet établissement depuis 2015 on
nous dit de patienter
que fait-on avec nos élèves
des épisodes de violence on a toujours
connu un mois en 25 ans j'en ai toujours
connu notre mouvement il n'est pas en
réaction à cette violence c'est cette
violence qui nous a permis de nous
révéler à nous mêmes
à quel point de situation devenait
dramatique à quel point notre analyse
depuis 5 6 ans était juste
[Musique]
alors ce qui peut nous faire arrêter
c'est d'avoir l'équivalent du ray durait
plus l'équivalent dans leur est plus il
faut savoir qu'il ya une prime également
pour les enseignants qui travaillent
dans des conditions comme ça un petit
peu plus difficile
cette prime est bien nous la demandons
même pas on fait pas ce métier pour
l'argent
le métier d'enseignant c'est une
vocation
[Musique]